we have the equation 3/4 X plus 2 is
equal to 3/8 X minus 4 now we could just
write from the get-go solve this way we
solved everything else group the X terms
maybe on the left hand side group the
constant terms on the right hand side
but adding and subtracting fractions are
messy so I'm going to do right from the
start of this video is to multiply both
sides of this equation by some number so
I can get rid of the fractions and the
best number to do it by what number is
the smallest number that if I multiply
both of these fractions by it they won't
be fractions anymore there'll be whole
numbers and that smallest number is
going to be 8 that smallest number is
going to be 8 I'm gonna multiply 8 times
both sides of this equation and you say
hey Sal how did you get 8 and I got 8
because I said well what's the least
common multiple of 4 and 8 well though
the smallest number that is divisible by
what 4 and 8 is 8 so when you multiply
by 8 it's going to get rid of the
fractions and see let's see what happens
so 8 times 3/4 that's the same thing as
8 times 3 over 4 let me do it on the
side over here that's the same thing as
8 times 3 over 4 which is equal to 8
divided by 4 is just 2 so it's 2 times 3
which is 6 so the left-hand side becomes
8 times 3/4 X is 6x and then 8 times 2
is 16 you have to remember when you
multiply both sides or a side of an
equation by a number you multiply every
term by that number so you have to
distribute the 8 so the left-hand side
is 6x plus 16 is going to be equal to 8
times 3/8 that's pretty easy the eights
cancel out and you're just left with 3x
and then 8 times negative 4 is negative
32 and now we've cleaned up the equation
a good bit now the next thing let's try
to get all the X terms on the left-hand
side and all the constant terms on the
right so let's get rid of this 3x from
the right let's subtract 3x from both
sides to do it that's the best way I can
think of getting the 3x get getting rid
of the 3x 4
the right the left-hand side of this
equation 6x minus 3x is 3x 6 minus 3 is
3 and then you have a plus 16 is equal
to 3x minus 3x that's the whole point of
subtracting 3x so they cancel out so
those guys cancel out and we're just
left with a negative 32 negative 32 now
let's get rid of the 16 from the
left-hand side so to get rid of it we're
going to subtract 16 from both sides of
this equation subtract 16 from both
sides the left-hand side of the equation
just becomes you have this 3x here these
16's cancel out you don't have to write
anything is equal to negative 32 minus
16 is negative 48 so we have 3x is equal
to negative 48 to isolate the X we can
just divide both sides of this equation
by 3 so let's divide both sides of that
equation by 3 the left-hand side of the
equation 3x divided by 3 is just an X
that was the whole point behind dividing
both sides by 3 and the right hand side
negative 48 divided by 3 is negative 16
negative 16 and we are done
x equals negative 16 is our solution so
let's make sure that this actually works
by substituting to the original equation
up here in the original equation didn't
have those eights out front so let's
substitute in the original equation we
get 3/4 3 over 4 times negative 16 times
negative 16 plus 2 plus 2 needs to be
equal to 3/8 times negative 16 times
negative 16 minus 4 minus 4 so 3/4 of 16
is 12 and you could think of it this way
what's 16 divided by 4 it is 4 and then
multiply that by 3 that's 12 this
mostess multiplying fraction so this is
going to be a negative 12 so we get
negative 12 plus 2 on the left hand side
negative 12 plus 2 is negative 10 so the
left-hand side is a negative 10 let's do
at the right hand let's see what the
right hand side is
with three-eighths times negative 16 if
you divide negative 16 by 8 you get
negative 2 times 3 is a negative 6 so
it's a negative 6 minus 4 negative 6
minus 4 is negative 10 so when X is
equal to negative 16 it does satisfy the
original equation both sides of the
equation become negative 10 and we are
done